from TV shows like finding your roots to
ancestry websites to companies offering
to analyze your DNA learning where we
come from has never been more popular
and it sent our next guest on a his own
journey of discovery author AJ Jacobs
put it all in his fascinating and funny
new book it's all relative adventures up
and down the worlds family tree
published by Simon & Schuster a division
of CBS AJ welcome thank you
what sets you off on this adventure well
a few years ago I got a very strange
email from a guy and he said you don't
know me but I'm your 8th cousin and I
figured ok he's gonna ask me to wire
$10,000 to Nigeria right but turns out
he was legit and he's one of these
people who are building the biggest
family tree in history literally
millions of people in dozens of
countries all on the same tree and it
just blew me away because I always
thought genealogy kind of stodgy a
little dull but no nowadays it is
fascinating and it affects every part of
our lives from politics to health to
race relations so I thought this has got
to be my next book yes and I actually am
working on a book that touches on my
ideas really fascinated in what you
found AJ at one point you tried to have
with the biggest family reunion in
history and an internee event you would
create it was called the global family
reunion what was that and how much of a
nightmare was well yes so the book is
part memoir part how to part science and
part my quest to throw the biggest
family reunion in history and I gotta
say that it was the strangest day of my
life we had we had a no spoilers but we
had 10,000 people all around the world
in different all singing we are family
to Sister Sledge at the same time he
weren't arguing over who makes the best
Thanksgiving turn well there was
probably a little about I am a cousin
science yeah they're all cousins so that
was the idea of the book that we are all
related but yeah this was we had quite
the variety we had a rabbi and a
minister and a Buddhist monk so it was
like the setup to a joke this whole
Julie genealogy has become a big
business hasn't a huge huge about
five million people have taken DNA tests
and there's genealogy shows and
genealogy cruises I think we all just
want to know where we come from there's
this desire like Who am I and this is
this is one way to find out you think
it's bringing us closer together well my
hope is yes that is part of the book is
that once you realize that we are all
cousins and we share 99.9 percent of our
DNA that maybe we can and there are some
studies that give me hope there's a
study about how when they showed
Palestinians and Israelis how closely
they're related they were kinder to each
other and more willing to negotiate so
that's the idea that you know our
parents always said we're all one big
family now you can see it now the
science is there to show what who were
you related to were your cousins well
pretty much as everyone but what I loved
is it was like the ultimate social
network because you could reach out you
know I would call Daniel Radcliffe and
I'd say this may sound weird but I'm
your second great uncle's third cousin
would you do with Solomon did he respond
and our King Lee enough
some of them that some probably got
restraining orders responded so I got
you know for the book I interviewed
everyone from David Blaine to George HW
Bush and Daniel you do raise some
questions about about privacy concerns
here with all this information that
people are sharing on genealogy right
yeah they're certainly like any
technology there is a risk so in the
future hackers may like get all of our
DNA and it'll be like that movie Gattaca
great movie but I think that the
benefits outweigh the risks and these
these companies are doing their best to
keep it private you took a number of
tests did they all return the same
results well it's funny I mean first of
all it turned out I am Jewish so that
was not one said that I was two and a
half percent Arabs so I was like I have
the Middle East conflict in my body your
papi that was a one said that I was 14
percent Scandinavian which was very
excited
but you know some of those data sets can
be a little bit funny
absolutely Alice you can read about more
in my fourth color you go I can't wait
well they are getting better the more
data they have yeah better than guys but
yeah as of now this thing AJ Jacobs were
really good I knew it
thank you cousins